governor steve says slack announced new
restrictions amid a rising covet cases
across the state
these new rules are in place now for the
next three weeks
bars and restaurants all across the
state are now scrambling to make these
changes
even more changes hector mejia is live
in the southwest valley with more on how
they're adjusting good morning to you
hector
hey there alex good morning the owner
here at parkway tavern said he was not
surprised to hear about the new
restrictions he does not anticipate
laying off employees
despite a potential loss in business and
the new restrictions we've been talking
about that they're dealing with
are now in place as you just mentioned
for the next three weeks
over at wolfgang puck players locker
they also plan to keep their staff
they told us they're managing schedules
to make sure everyone gets some work
time
tom kaplan senior managing partner says
they're just happy restaurants were not
shut down
and that they were able to open at 25
capacity yesterday they welcomed guests
for lunch for the first time
with the new capacity regulation in
place
we were sort of anticipating this change
seeing the medical numbers
reading what we read we knew this was
coming this is the right thing to do
this is not political it's medical
and we need to do the right thing for
our community
here's a breakdown of the changes for
the next three weeks restaurants and
bars can only have indoor and outdoor
seating at 25 percent
capacity public gatherings are limited
to 50 people or 25
capacity whichever is less as far as
private gatherings well those can only
have as many as
10 people from no more than two
households
masks are required everywhere both
indoors and outdoors
and the new state requirements also
require reservations at bars and
restaurants
reporting live in the southwest valley
this morning hector mejia
8 news now